provide an amazing experience one of
things I'm a big believer up is you want
to provide a great experience to the
people who are your customers who are
interested in what you're doing so that
every interaction with you every step
along the way from how they find out
about you to how they deal with you when
they're buying two after the purchase is
an enjoyable one is one where they want
to go and talk about you it's something
that we're focusing one of our key
priorities that Toronto that salsa here
is creating a remarkable experience
something that is so good that when
people leave they want to make a remark
about it right they want to tell people
about it because word-of-mouth marketing
is the most affordable way to grow
business and unless you have tons of
cash you know burning a hole in your
pocket you can't afford to go and take
out super bowl commercial ads you need
to have your customers saying good
things about you and it's not that your
customers aren't it's just that are they
telling it with enough passion like just
doing the job isn't enough if you just
do what I ask you to do I'm satisfied
but am I going to go and brag about you
to all my friends and say man this
person was so amazed and it was so
awesome to deal with them that's the
difference and so you need to not just
do the job we need to go way above and
beyond so that people want to go and
talk about you so I want to share an
example as it comes through on the book
one of the things that I do for
everybody who buys a book is I make a
video thanking them for the book we're
at 180 sales I think now and so I've
made 180 videos for people almost some
of their bulk orders but 150 plus videos
that's a lot of videos thinking people
one by one for buying the book and the
response is always amazing people always
writing to say thank you so much for
making that video and its true like
somebody spending nineteen dollars for a
book or fourteen dollars or thirteen
dollars for the e-book version it's not
a lot of money i see like pretty much
zero of that anyway and i'm spending
time making a personalized video just
for them but it's that experience that I
22 because I wanted to encourage them I
want to support them I want them to feel
good for having about the book I want
them to one that comes in to actually
read the book because I put a lot of a
lot of love into that there's a lot of
heart in there that I want them to pay
attention to and so that that's my hope
it's not just a marketing thing though
it's not just that like I'm doing
something go tell their friends I'm
doing because i actually care about them
because i want them to have a great
experience in dealing with me and my
business and so what i wanted to share
was an example of a video that i made
for one of my buyers tamyra Campbell
joins a company called Tim cam photo and
I made a video for her was just over a
minute thinking her for buying and she
made a really touching video response
back to me if I want to share that as
well to show you the impact that doing
something that doesn't take a lot of
time can have on a customer's life and
if you do that consistently you're going
to get a lot of good word of mouth for
your business what's up tomorrow happy
Wednesday I saw your email I love the
energy and enthusiasm when you wrote hi
evidence stuff and then have three
exclamation marks after it I'm feeling
the love it's a great way to get some
energy on a Wednesday well afternoon
right now I see you from Dallas which is
awesome I've never been to dallas but
there's a lot of people who are buying
from dallas in from Texas my aging is in
Dallas so I'm gonna have to make a trip
to Dallas I know to make a trip to
Dallas and take some pictures with
tamiya Campbell that's what's up anyway
I'm about to film my videos for the week
to the YouTube channel once they thank
you take a quick timeout because I
really appreciate your support and
humbled that you would pick up my book
and support me and super curious to find
out what you thought about the book when
it comes out how to impact you you know
what what are you going to use in your
business to your life so hit me up we
actually getting your hands and that you
start plowing through it that's it
tomorrow i hope you have a great rest of
the week thank you again for the support
you need to believe or whatever your one
where it is and I'll see you soon hi
Evan this is tomorrow Campbell from
Dallas dude thank you so much for
sending me that that video I mean it was
just what I needed at that exact moment
um like I said in my email I've been
going through such a hard time in the
last few days trying to work on a new
business venture while making sure that
my photography business is still you
know running accordingly and dude seeing
you um just take the time to do what you
just did you know is amazing oh they
always say it they always say that
there's six degrees of separation from
each person and I can't believe you're
your agent is right here in Dallas so I
cannot wait to meet you I'm pretty sure
you're gonna probably be coming to
dallas pretty soon as your book launches
and december and i'm going to be the
first person in line to meet you and
create more value for what you are
giving out to the world i'm going to
find a way to to spread the word about
your book and purchase more under my
name I work with a lot of high schoolers
and they can definitely use some
inspiration um you know based on their
backgrounds on whether you come from
because you know you have inspired me
and I don't come from a background of
abundance um I had to learn all of this
myself so with that being said thank you
again so much I'm super super grateful
for you oh that I found someone like you
who will who has inspired me and much
success Oh take care dude when you come
down here you definitely definitely um
you have a Texas barbecue meal waiting
for you take care thank you so much so
thank you tomorrow for that awesome
video I hope you guys go check out of a
Tam cam photo com will link it up in the
description as well so provide an
amazing experience for your customers
and they will reward you with more
purchases and word-of-mouth referrals so
let's get to the questions first up is
next time tech for videos up today
you're killing it thanks man there's a
love-hate relationship with some people
in the video quantity i made a video
about that explaining why i make so many
so i'm glad you appreciate the hustle
hopefully you're learning
from it and thank you for that comment I
think the most we've done seven live
streams on one day and my aim is for
ctrader to make it really valuable and
helpful if I'm proud of everything that
we put out and I'm glad that that you're
enjoying it next new feature builder
Evan the first five minutes of this
video geesh you shared some strong stuff
here on this channel but the one word
portion hit me hard then I even got
something irritating my eye Wow I'll
have to look at the rest of my life and
see how else I can hashtag build better
stronger even more consistently and have
you considered starting a viral contest
/ campaign to spread even more awareness
about the book any holiday style
promotions coming down the line I
appreciate the feedback I'm open to
ideas this was the first time so last
week when I shared about how to make a
credo it's a key part of what's in the
book it's the first time I think I
talked a lot about one of the specific
examples in the book so maybe I should
be doing that more if you are in love
with it and getting kind of teary eyed
watching it so that that's some quality
feedback I've been doing some excerpt
and we've done two already where I'm
reading one of the pages from the book
to kind of highlight some of the topics
that I'm talking about maybe I should go
more in-depth let me know you want you
guys want me to like talk about a
different story each week in the book
maybe and shed an example right now I've
been talking about about the process of
writing the book and promoting the book
much more than the content of the book
but if you guys are curious about that
let me know what maybe I'll adjust the
series or split it up to be able to
share some of that with you in terms of
contests and promotions again I'm open
to you your your feedback and
suggestions we're going to start hitting
a little bit harder mid month I'm going
in next week i think the start recording
the audio versions there's a lot of
momentum is going to be building and
happening and hopefully that leads to a
lot of impact and awareness for the book
so thank you for your support next up
ara are a car Rishi adoro a cottage
chula let's go with that I Evan I like
that I oven you guys should start with I
Evan more your book is going to leave a
positive impact personally I applaud the
publication of your wonderful book I
can't wait to have it I think I told you
already just thinking on it is helping
me our
look forward to my hashtag one word
everywhere ads cars models food packages
t-shirt slogans you put a lot of effort
time and thought into it so it'll be
rewarded you've worked hard to achieve
this so it will help 173 people and me
before helping 174,000 wishing you best
of luck in your new capacity author hey
thank you for the love really appreciate
that and it's true once you identify
what it is you'll start to notice things
differently in your environment when you
find your one word you'll find a lot of
things in your environment that do
support it that then you start
gravitating towards you start attracting
higher quality people things experiences
into your life and also it shines a
light on some of the things in your life
that are not congruent not aligned with
what you should be doing and helps you
make tougher decisions a lot more easily
so I'm glad that you're already starting
to realize that without even having a
copy of the book and I'm excited to see
your growth once you get your hands on
it or ears on it next up chorea Thank
You Evan to you and your team for all
the support of making these videos
buying a book for all the knowledge that
we get every single day isn't nothing
thank you I appreciate the support i
appreciate whether you're buying one
book or ten books or more I appreciate
the support wherever it comes and also
because i really put a lot of work and
love into this i truly believe in the
ideas in this book that it's not just
hey you know donate to my channel
because i make good videos the concepts
here will have a dramatic impact on your
life and your business and i really want
to see that get into your hands you can
start seeing dramatic growth in the
areas that you want to next up Lauren
Crawford I watched most of your videos
hear you talk about the book is making
me want to read it great advice so
another one where I'm talking about the
book at you guys are interested so again
i'm curious should i be talking more
about what's in the book in these book
videos i'm leaning towards it yes but
but let me know what you guys think it's
this is great feedback I appreciate it
elegant style and beauty hey Evan have
you got any tips on how to grow your
YouTube channel I've talked about this a
lot into multiple different videos maybe
just to quickly summarize a one I would
say you have to be talking about
something that you're deeply passionate
about and want to want to you know make
an impact on to you got to find how
you're different what's unique special
about you you're talking about elegant
style and beauty
of style and beauty youtube channels
what is different about you that doesn't
exist anywhere else a lot of that comes
from what you stand for whether it's
your one word like what do you stand for
is a human being and how do you bring
that to your business to have spread a
message not just teach me how to dress
better or have better style but spread a
message to make me feel something
whether that's you know more confident
more pretty more validated whatever it
is if you can make me feel something
beyond just teaching me a trick you're
much more likely to get an audience and
then just being consistent consistent
consistent consistent my channel took
off really as i started making daily
videos instead of just once a week or
once a month every day and then twice a
day and then three times a day but that
jumped from once a week to everyday made
a huge difference in the growth of my
channel 1 because i'm just making more
content and two because it I have to
practice more so I get better right the
more you practice your piano the better
you get the more you practice ski jumps
the better you're going to get the more
you practice making YouTube videos the
better you're going to get and so you're
you're increasing the rate of production
from one video to seven a week which
gives you the content but also helps you
become better at being on camera and
making videos so those things that
really helped me and I hope they will
help you next up Malik brand hey I'm
needing your channel first off I want to
say your videos are great I love your
top 10 rules Elliott Hulse is one of my
mentors and I'm wondering if you can do
one on my other mentor Jason capital if
you would do that there'd be amazing I
told Ellie about your video and he loved
it hope to hear from you soon Thank You
Malik for the support for any top 10
video leaving a comment if you have a
suggestion for somebody my team picks it
up and then we start ranking them by
who's got the most requests and then we
make it up so if you want who we have
here Jason capital tell all your friends
to come and leave comments for Jason
capital it'll boost them up in the
rankings and I'm a fan of elliott hulse
as well we did a top 10 on him he
commented on that video so if you go to
the elliott hulse top 10 you'll see his
comments somewhere in there of
appreciation it's great that he's back
because he took this long hiatus from
making videos and I've noticed that he's
back with it with a new twist but it's
awesome hearing him
back on YouTube and seeing his passion
come through the camera and it's great
that you're connected to him as well so
thank you for the love next up is Paul
in the beginning with the Credo it's
scary opposite disappointing yes I keep
plucking along thanks hashtag BTW a319
hashtag secret self-made billionaires
hash like 319 that's some consistency
Paul I love that so in last video I
talked about making a credo figure out
what your one word is and then the three
things that that make it up and that
helps become the blueprint for how you
live your life and it gave a couple of
examples and and it can be disappointing
for some people some people have a high
level self-awareness and just
immediately know what it what it is for
them they're one word and there are
three things underneath you know I took
me a long time and for others it takes
him a long time I didn't have the
blueprint i wish i had this would have
been a lot easier but don't get
discouraged right just like anything
else if you stick with it it'll come
much more importantly to find the thing
that really resonates with you so you
know for Alex who's been on the channel
number times from China dance salsa his
one word is belong and then on there he
has validation validating people not
judging people no judgment and welcome
people with opening arms and so
everything that he does has to fall into
the those things he wants to create a
life and a business around making people
feel like they belong and how does he do
that by validating people in every
conversation by welcoming them and by
trying not to judge them and so there's
a constant reminder to him for how he
wants to live his life and also for
people who are super judgmental maybe
they don't belong in his life he's gonna
he's gonna constantly battle with people
who are very judgmental who don't accept
people with open arms and now he knows
why he knows why because this is his
credo this is what he's all about the
ties to his one word where before he
would just fight and try to struggle
through that relationship having that
better awareness makes it easier for you
to make those hard decisions but yes
like much more important than getting
three things down on paper is that they
are actually true in court to you I gave
you a high-level example in the video
the book obviously goes until them into
a lot more detail it's you know it's got
some thickness to it I guess part of the
fear of sharing too much is that
too much a part of the fear of sharing
some of the content in the book is that
it's not giving you the total answer
right where there's I don't want you
guys to feel disappointed or you don't
understand it or you don't have all the
context because i'm giving you a high
level without going into all the
specifics so i'll have to work that one
through because i like that you're
making progress i love that you're
learning and you're applying it but you
need to have the full details able to
really figure it out and get the
leverage so i'll think about it thank
you for bringing that up you doc hello
Evan I was just curious to know where to
pre-order the book so that best helps
you and you can be notified about it
thanks I appreciate the love you doc
that that means a lot it's just going to
add vikarma calm / one word you can buy
it from most of the retailers whether
it's amazon or barnes & noble or you
know whatever wherever you buy it you
can get a ebook you can get an audio
book whatever it makes the most sense
for you if you're buying in bulk of 10
or more you get significant discounts
and there's a link there of how to grow
and do that just notify me send an email
we have a there's an email address on
the website just make sure you check
that on email in your receipt otherwise
we don't we don't have a way of keeping
track I can't give you a shadow in the
video I can't give you the bonuses and I
can't update the numbers because we
don't have your receipt and so just
emailing that in the publisher doesn't
give us great data until after
everything has been released and we
don't know who will just have numbers
and so I want to make sure that I can
make a video for you and I can
appreciate you and there's no easy way
to do it apart from you emailing in your
receipts so send that in is the best way
to do it and then in terms of sharing it
and letting people know again whatever
whatever you feel is best if there's
somebody you think would be of interest
if one of your friends you know has a
blog or a YouTube channel that might be
a fit for what I'm doing I don't want
anything to be a hard sell but if you
think that there's a fit somewhere i'm
happy to listen and be a part of a
conversation and last up is coolin who's
saying I hashtag believe you're going to
sell 1 million copies in the first week
that would be amazing that would really
be amazing I'm going to channel that
feeling I really appreciate the support
of all you guys and I'm excited to
finally get this out and into people's
hands december six is when it comes out
it's a long way away but as we move into
October now it's feeling more and more
like it's happening and so I'm super
pumped and so I'd love to know what you
guys think about the topic at the top
which was creating a remarkable
experience how are you guys doing it do
you have questions about how to create
it I'd also love to know your thoughts
about should I include more the book
content some of the topics in these
videos for you guys to learn a little
bit more about it and of course if you
have questions about the book or the
book writing process leave in the
comments below and I will answer it for
you guys next week thank you so much for
watching I really appreciate you and all
your support continue to believe or
whatever your one word is and I'll see
you soon